ein terroranschlag von islamisten
verhindert und das mitten in
deutschlands in düren in nordrhein
westfalen diese nachricht hat uns
aufgeschreckt eine neue terrorzelle
offenbar mit einem halben dutzend sehr
junger männer die sich in einem wald
getroffen haben um zu trainieren für
einen anschlag kommt dieser
islamistische terror mit wucht wieder zu
uns ja mit dieser frage haben sich seit
bekanntwerden dieser razzia unsere
reporter beschäftigt im speck und unser
chefreporter polizeireporter frank
schneider und während dieser reportage
von tim specks gestern aus türen
passierte plötzlich das hier er wurde
nämlich auf der strasse attackiert
offenbar von sympathisanten dieser
islamistenszene in düren
die säulen einen terroristischen akt
also ein terroranschlag vorbereitet
haben und zwar in anlehnung an opa
gander material des und ich glaube wir
müssen jetzt eben ein paar meter zur
seite gehen wäre nämlich hier
angegriffen gerade von ihm
ermöglicht ihren ideen nicht an die tür
wir gehen einmal ganz kurz raus hier aus
dem aktuellen bild sagen wir können
jetzt noch mal
ich glaube
du kannst die situation sicher besser
einschätzen ja das war also gestern nach
diesem vorfall waren wir natürlich mit
unserem reporter tim specks sprechen
hören wie es ihm heute geht er ist uns
jetzt zugeschaltet schönen guten morgen
tim
ja gestern wurde sie attackiert in
unserer live schalte beschreibt uns noch
einmal diesen moment und wieder auch
jetzt damit umgeht ist
ja die wichtigste nachricht erst mal
zuerst also die hat auch die kamera es
gut wir sind körperlich unversehrt
geblieben natürlich hatten wir erst mal
einen ganz schönen schock in den knochen
wenn damit rechnet man ja nicht
unbedingt dass man eben bereich der
portale dermaßen angegangen wird ja was
ist passiert wir waren eben vor einer
dieser wohnungen wo es eine durchsuchung
jetzt und und bei der ersten recherche
vor ort habe gemerkt das ist vielleicht
ein ziemlich heißes pflaster ist wo wir
unterwegs sind denn man hat uns sofort
eine tür auf gesagt dass wir doch besser
ein paar meter zurück gehen vielleicht
auch ganz weg denn die tiere hier würden
leute sagen die nicht lange fackelte und
das haben ein paar minuten später schon
gemerkt das sind leute die nicht lange
fackeln das ist ein heißes pflaster
sagst du tim düren das ist offenbar ein
kleiner sport aber ein hotspot der
islamistenszene
naja also zumindest lassen diese
durchsuchung gestern darauf schließen
dass dort einige sind hat die sache ist
jetzt unterwegs sind ins ganz fünf orte
an denen untersucht wurde mit 350
beamten im ganzen landkreis düren
zwischen köln und aachen und auch wenn
es nicht so aus lahde waren ja jetzt
dann dort unterwegs war eine ruhige
nachbarschaft glaubt man nicht dass da
eine mutmaßliche vorbereitungen
terrorakt stattfindet aber da sieht man
eben auch das ist eine trügerische
sicherheit ist über die nachbarschaft
ebenso ausgesetzt mich dass da
vielleicht auch solche dinge passieren
im speck vielen dank dir schöne system
gut geht und wir gehen darüber zu
unserem chefreporter frank schneider wir
müssen weiter über diese razzia gestern
sprechen und auch über die gefahr die
derzeit droht die gefahr anlage wollen
wir von dir eingeschätzt haben schönen
guten morgen frank einmal zu gestern
terrornetz wurde ausgewogen wie
gefährlich waren diese männer was genau
ist dort gestern passiert
wenn man erst mal sieht dass niemand
festgenommen und auch keine haftbefehle
vollstreckt wurden dann denkt man ja
erstmal naja so schlimm kann es nicht
gewesen sein wenn man einmal dann
gestern die details wird die auch der
innenminister selber bekannt gegeben hat
dann ist man schon geschockt weil es
handelt sich um eine siebenköpfige
gruppe relativ jung 16 bis 22 der
vermutliche anführer dieser gruppe ist
der 22-jährige der rest ist wie gesagt
erst 16 bis 18 es handelt sich um sechs
mit deutschem pass zwei jahren
zusätzlich einen russischen pass und
einer in türkischen es sind aber alles
polizeibekannte personen und zwar
handelt es sich um sechs gefährder und
wer als gefährder eingestuft wird von
dem kann man annehmen er könnte ein
terror anschlag begehen das heißt die
polizei hatte sie zum glück bereits auf
dem schirm und der siebte ist eine so
genannte relevante person auch jemand
aus dem islamistischen umfeld und wenn
man dann noch hört vom innenminister
dass man bei durchsuchungen schon
machten messer äxte gefunden hat ein
teleskop schlagstock pfefferspray dann
weiß man offenbar waren da schon
vorbereitungen im gange und es soll auch
ein training gegeben haben im wald wo
man mit messern und äxten trainiert hat
wie man möglichst viele menschen
angreift und dann sagte der
innenminister noch und das war das was
uns alle schockiert hat die gruppe hatte
kontakt zu personen die kurz vor dem
anschlag in wien und das ist jetzt fast
genau ein jahr her dass war am zweiten
november letzten jahres die personen
haben diesen an täter in wien besucht
die kommen aus deutschland und diese
genau diese gleichen personen die
kontakt hatten zu diesem attentäter
waren auch kurz vorher bei dieser gruppe
in düren und das zeigt diese brisanz und
dimension und darüber sind die
ermittlungen auch in gang gekommen vor
einem jahr und dann hat die polizei
hervorragend gearbeitet hat akribisch
ermittelt hat offen auch
telefonüberwachung durchgeführt
operationen durchgeführt und dann kam es
gestern eben zu diesem polizeieinsatz
um zu verhindern dass diese person
wirklich einen anschlag verüben können
also fragen der islamisten zelle dort in
düren junge männer die verbindung haben
zu diesen attentätern in wien die
trainieren mit macheten unter anderem im
wald regelmäßig für einen möglichen
terroranschlag das klingt wirklich
bedrohlich jetzt hast du auch gesagt
keine haftbefehle die leute laufen da
weiter frei herum wer passten jetzt ganz
naiv gefragt im moment auf die auf
naja da hört sich natürlich die polizei
in schweigen aber man kann davon
ausgehen dass diese personen im blick
behalten werden man könnte auch davon
ausgehen dass sie möglicherweise
observiert werden dass der staatsschutz
genau weiß was sie machen denn das kann
man ja nicht riskieren und man wollte
mit diesem einsatz möglicherweise auch
beweismittel auf in um dann vielleicht
sie doch in untersuchungshaft nehmen zu
können wie das ausgeht auch insbesondere
die auswertung der datenträger also
handys laptops und ähnliches das muss
man jetzt abwarten werden da genug
beweise gefunden wir haben das ja in
hagen erlebt vor wenigen wochen das hat
ja auch ein minderjähriger offenbar
einen anschlag auf eine synagoge geplant
und da haben die ja auch bei den
durchsuchungen beweise gefunden
hinterher gereicht haben dass er jetzt
in untersuchungshaft sitzt auch wegen
vorbereitung einer schweren
staatsgefährdenden gewalttat so heißt
das ja im juristendeutsch aber dass man
hier diese person die justiz keine
anlass war diese personen in haft zu
nehmen wundert mich ehrlich gesagt auch
als gestern der innenminister verkündet
hat klingt schon sehr bedrohlich ja
frank schneider unser chefreporter
vielen herzlichen dank hierfür eine
einschätzungen
und wir sprechen er weiter über diese
razzia gestern in düren und zugeschaltet
ist uns jetzt terrorismus experte peter
neumann einen schönen guten tag herr
neumann kommt jetzt der terror zurück
nach deutschland
also der terror ist niemals hat niemals
deutschland verlassen der terror bei dem
hier und zwar während der gesamten
letzten jahre und jahrzehnte hatten
immer islamistische aktivität es gibt
über 500 in deutschland bekannte
islamistische gefährder immer noch
aktuell und hierbei hat es sich
offensichtlich auch um welche gehandelt
also das ist niemals ganz verschwunden
sehr junger männer hat unser bild
chefreporter frank schneider ja eben
gesagt halbstarke terror bubis würde ich
mal sagen aber wie gefährlich sind diese
terror bubis
also die sind schon sehr gefährlich und
ich glaube es ist ein wähler das
irgendwie
bloß weil jetzt nicht aussehen wie james
bond oder wie professionell terroristen
dass man glaubt die seien nicht
gefährlich man sieht eben in den letzten
jahren ganz häufig dass dort sind die
eigentlich in man nicht so viel zutrauen
und mit den einfachsten mitteln sei es
mit messern oder mit fahrzeugen durchaus
sehr viele menschen töten können und
natürlich auch viele terror und wie
panik in der gesellschaft sein seit
tatsache dass das dass das junge leute
sind dass das nicht besonders gut
ausgebildete leute sind leute die man
vielleicht nicht besonders viel zutrauen
würde bedeutet nicht dass die nicht auch
gefährlich sein
wie funktioniert die szene denn genau
wie werden die jungen menschen
angeworben werden sich radikalisiert
also die meisten die jetzt in der szene
drin sind die sind eigentlich schon seit
ein paar jahren
letzten jahren ist wissen dass zähne
nicht besonders viel passiert der grund
dafür ist einfach
der sogenannte islamische staat wurde in
syrien und im irak besiegt es gab eine
niederlage der interessierten aus der
2015/16 existiert hat ist weg das heißt
es sind wenige leute dazu kommen die
leute die jetzt dabei sind sind schon
seit einiger zeit dabei und die sind
eben leute die sich über den salafismus
in den sogenannten dschihadismus
radikalisiert haben salafismus ist ein
ganz ganz extreme ausprägung des
islamischen glaubens und innerhalb des
islamismus gibt es wieder verschiedene
strömungen der dschihadismus der
gewalttätige salafismus das ist eine
davon und in die sind eben mit letzten
jahrzehnts viele leute rein gerutscht
jetzt passiert diese radikalisierung
halt irgendwo wie hier in diesem fall in
düren in der relativ friedlich
aussehenden straße da radikalisieren
sich diese männer plötzlich was kann der
staat tun damit das eben genau nicht
passierte neumann
ja es gibt prävention und die
funktioniert auch in vielen teilen
deutschlands es gibt überall in
deutschland jones anbieter die haben
auch mittlerweile relativ viele viele
jahre an erfahrung und mit vielen bands
und gearbeitet
und natürlich hört man immer davon wenn
was schiefgeht das heißt wenn dann mal
prävention nicht klappt aber in den
vielen fällen in denen es klappt von
denen hört man eben häufig relativ wenig
dabei ist es schon wichtig dass wenn zum
beispiel eltern sehen dass ihr kind in
die salafistische szene rein schildert
dass sie einen ansprechpartner haben der
ansprechpartner an dem punkt ist dann
eben meistens nicht die polizei weil
diese person hat ja noch keine straftat
begangen hat auf möglicherweise
überhaupt nicht vor eine straftat zu
begehen ist aber dabei in den
extremismus hineinzusteigern und an dem
punkt an diesem frühen punkt an denen
sind präventions- anbieter wichtig denn
diese die experten dafür wie man eine
weitere entwicklung in diese richtung
verhindert wie man also zum beispiel
eltern und er hoffen und dabei hilft
nicht weiter in diese szene ein
zusteller